this is one of the top five chapters in
all of one piece and if you haven't read
it yet fly you fool and only come back
once you have but if you have welcome to
another week of me breaking my vow to
not talk about a new chapter for the
second time in a row now i have so many
theories to share told you so's to say
and things to analyze here like here's a
quick recap you know just in case you
forgot what happened already luffy has
fully awakened his devil fruit which he
has now declared his gear fifth the
gorosei revealed that the real name of
the gomu gomo nomi is actually the
mythical human human zone fruit model
nika very likely the most powerful devil
fruit out there and while it seems that
luffy hasn't exactly been possessed by
joyboy he clearly isn't quite himself
either his battle with kaido is
absolutely borrow breathtaking see what
i did there
and kaido apologizing to luffy is
exactly in line with my character
analysis of him i published just two
days ago then there's also the
ridiculous fact that luffy's hair has
turned into fire like in this sketch
that oda made of luffy as street fighter
ken also his eyebrows have started
curling very similar to sanji
and his eyes take on the same ring-like
shape that is shared by a very crazy and
select group of characters emu mihawk
and zunisha so that's all that all about
also what a power move by oda calling it
the nikanika fruit remember how people
thought it had to be the gomu gomu nomi
because of the word plays with the straw
hats devil fruits all numbers from one
to ten choppers hitohito nomi is one in
ten broxio miyomi is four and three
robin's hanahana was eight and seven and
luffy was go mu so five and six so that
left two and nine which led people to
believe that it might be kuma's sneak
unique fruit
[Music]
well turns out it's not me cubert nicar
another reading for nine luffy was two
and nine after all and that now leaves
five and six open again and the only
fruit we now actually know that fits
this is enel's goro goro no me just
throwing it out there not saying
anything
now once again it was as impossible to
escape spoilers for all this for even a
minute as it is to take a poop without
your phone imagine so of course as soon
as there was so much as a whisper about
what would happen in the chapter the
comment sections under like my last 10
videos all were flooded my twitter was
flooded people were nailing printouts of
the spoilers to my door okay or maybe
not that last one but you know that's
what it felt like and so apparently my
way of teaching people a lesson and
saying that that's not okay is by giving
in to their demands and actually talking
about this right now but then also if
this doesn't have your blood boiling i
don't know what will i will dissect for
you what exactly this mythical creature
nika is supposed to be and what its true
powers are now before dedicating this
entire video to luffy and kaido i want
to at least acknowledge quickly the
scene between hiori and orochi with this
sentence or two as well even though
let's be real no one really cares in the
context of this chapter but still i
found it both very surprising and
satisfying to see orochi dying at the
hands of kandero especially because it
was his own fault when you really think
about it
orochi literally told him to cast
everyone in the castle into the abyss of
hell and free their souls kanjiro free
us in a blaze of glory us free us in a
blaze of glory that's literally what
oroshi said to which contrary responded
well as you wish please enjoy my final
show the suicide pact of the kuruzumi
clan galaxy brain move right there from
orochi once again really funny stuff but
not as funny as what's up next
so here's actually my first i told you
so moment that sounds a little bit cocky
but i have to take the few wins i can
get at least luffy is a mythical zone
fruit as fun as that resin idea was as
one hilarious comment in my video
pointed out it did make very little
sense for the government to rename the
resin fruit into the rubber fruit i mean
as if anyone would go oh no it was the
resin fruit all along now i really wish
i had got my hands on that one and so
all mythical fruits we've gotten so far
with the sole exceptions of sengoku and
katarina devon who might very well still
appear in this arc actually have been in
wano and both the buddha and kitsune are
heavily connected to japanese culture
and so as i've mentioned in a bunch of
videos already wano is based on the
story of momotaro momotaro with the help
of a pheasant a dog and a monkey goes to
onigashima to defeat the oni so we do
have kaido the oni a mythical zone momo
momotaro a mythical zone the same one
actually you have the mythical dog
yamato the mythical bird marco and so
there was really just one logical
candidate left for the mythical monkey
fruit usopp i'm just messing with you
and so it turns out that luffy's rub
abilities are just a natural property of
the sangothnica similarly to how marco
has access to fire or how yamato can
create ice in other words it's the
paramecia properties of a mythical zone
[Music]
and so changing its name to the gumu
gomo no me the rubber fruit was actually
pretty smart because it basically
reduces the nika fruit to its most
unimpressive ability rubber it's kind of
like saying that marco's fruit is a
weaker version of asus mira miranomi or
that sengoku actually has the gold gold
fruits or something along those lines
okay so just to summarize now luffy has
a mythical zone fruit power advanced
forms of all three types of hockey and
an awakened devil fruit oh yeah plus the
voice of all things so i think it's
pretty fair to say that this is pretty
close to endgame luffy right now alright
i do stand by my idea however that luffy
will have to learn to control and use
his awakening after wano i really doubt
and would be kind of strange also if it
would be something he can just do every
single time from now on whenever he
wants to right and so luffy turning out
to be a zone type is actually also
incredibly funny in retrospect remember
this panel where momo asks luffy how he
can turn back into his human form of
punk hazards luffy literally says don't
ask me i'm not a zone fruit
well turns out luffy you are and you
basically have spent your entire life in
your hybrid form since you were like
eight years old which is just such a
luffy thing to do and in a way the scene
was pretty big foreshadowing as well
because momo and luffy as far as i can
remember at least are the only two
people in the entire story that truly
struggled with their devil fruit powers
after they got them other characters
like khalifa for example could just use
their fruit pretty decently right away
because they fully understand what their
power actually is luffy however thinks
that his fruit is the rubber fruit
making it incredibly hard to work with
at the beginning because that's just not
what it is it's a zone
and by the way let's be real it also
explains pretty pretty nicely luffy's
crazy stamina and endurance as well as
his fast recovery time because that's
exactly the benefits of all zone fruits
and mythical zones in particular
are associated with that and on top of
all that we have another straw head with
a human type devil fruit chopper who
makes all of this so much more
interesting in retrospect
luffy's gear system for instance is very
very similar to choppers different point
forms and so while everyone was looking
at katakuri and doffy for when it comes
to luffy's possible awakening chopper
was there all along his point system and
luffy's gear system and so monster point
in particular might be truly
foreshadowing for a giant form of luffy
which looking at his giant arm in this
chapter is very possible i mean then he
could also be wearing that giant straw
hat that's hidden away at marijuana i'm
just saying also chopper turning into
this gb form here early in the raid also
reminded me a lot of tiny luffy before
he was able to control gear third
also after the time skip they both came
back able to switch between different
forms with little to no setback and
effort and so to me the only real
question is will luffy eat a rumble ball
and what the hell will happen when he
does but let's talk a little bit about
the fruit itself shall we clearly shanks
knew exactly what it was when he stole
it shanks was clearly tasked by roger to
find the right person to become joy boy
and so he had no other chance really but
to bet everything on luffy the only
person who now could actually become joy
boy because he ate the devil fruit
[Music]
that means rayleigh knew as well of
course which is i guess why he was so
surprised to see how luffy used his
fruits powers despite only being aware
of a fraction of its true capabilities
and it also makes you wonder if it
wasn't blackbeard but actually luffy
that shanks wanted to talk to the
gorosei about when he visited marijuana
him telling them about luffy having the
fruit which is how they might have found
out in the first place but i still don't
think honestly that it's very likely
that shanks is a villain of the story
but it definitely makes you questions
his motives just a little bit but who
knows maybe shanks knew that luffy would
have to die in order to awaken it and
push the government to make a hasty move
as they ended up doing in the end not
fully understanding how that fruit
worked though i do feel like that would
be a very detailed plan to say the least
so not sure if shanks is that level of
mastermind but maybe he is who knows
similarly to that i guess it's possible
that blackbeard did confuse the yummy
yummy nomi with the nika nikanomi but
honestly i personally think that those
two fruits look very similar for a
reason they probably are a sort of pair
the sun and darkness and that would
actually also make sense thematically
because luffy's rubber powers are also a
wonderful counter to the guragura nomi's
earthquake abilities
the only question i'm asking myself here
again is if blackbeard should acquire a
third devil fruit what would luffy's
third ability be just some food for
thought i guess now as we now got
confirmed the gumu gomu no me or rather
than nika nikonomi wow this is probably
gonna take a while to get used to huh so
the nikka nika no me was a key
ingredient in awakening joy boy it seems
now you might have seen my video on the
true nature of devil fruits in which i
lay out proof for these fruits being
alive and carrying on the will of their
previous owner if you haven't i heavily
recommend you check that out later in
full because i think it makes a ton of
sense now because we literally get the
confirmation for that from the gorosei
themselves zone fruits in particular
have a will of their own which makes
sense because all the objects that have
eaten devil fruits that we've seen in
the story like the sword funk freed or
the cannon that became a dog whose name
i've forgotten on alabaster they've all
had zone fruits and took on that
animal's personality
and caesar smile fruits were also all
based on animals for some weird reason
they're called smiles as if in reference
to joy boy smile so maybe the smiles
were also part of kaido's plan to awaken
joy boys somehow and it's also ironic
that he now will be defeated by the only
true smile devil fruit who knows maybe
this is also the answer to vegapunk
deeming momo's fruit a failure maybe he
was just able to replicate the food's
abilities but could not actually inherit
the will of the original into that copy
that seems to be important because quote
unquote luffy's fruit was trying to
escape the hands of the government for
800 years now i think it's pretty much
confirmed at this point right that the
nika fruit used to belong to joyboy and
so as i've speculated for a while now it
seems like eating the nikanika fruit
inherited part of joyboy's will and
personality on sulufi in a way that
could mean that we've just been
following luffy and joyboy's adventure
in one basically i don't think however
that luffy became who he is because of
eating that fruit i think that shanks
wanted to give this fruit to ace the son
of his former captain roger who wanted
kids in order to create joy boy
and so i think what happened is that
while looking for ace and fuchsia
village the will of joy boy in the fruit
chose luffy as its worthy owner i guess
think of it in terms of thor's hammer
luffy always was the embodiment of what
it meant to be joy boy he has been
freeing people from their burden and
bringing joy and hope his entire life i
mean he literally liberated every one of
his crew members freeing zorro from his
capture nami from her burden robin from
the darkness broke from his loneliness
and so on and so forth
[Music]
he freed people like had a curry from
his burden to be the perfect older
brother ace from his captivity well more
or less i guess and of course entire
countries from their tyrannical rulers
it's luffy's entire character arc
liberation joy boys drums of liberation
and so now here in wano where luffy is
fighting and dying for the liberation of
the people of wano in the night of the
fire festival where they sent their
prayers to the spirits of their
ancestors joy boy's will has finally
acknowledged luffy's spirit and awakened
the true power of the sun god powers for
the first time in 800 years luffy's
heartbeat has now literally become the
drums of liberation the sound that
brings hope to the oppressed another i
told you so moment by the way because i
mentioned in the last chapter how hola
sensei put a lot of focus on that heart
sound effect in luffy's close-up also i
absolutely loved kaido's reaction to
luffy being alive this chapter i already
love him more and more as a villain the
more we see of him and apologizing to
luffy for how he won this fight unfairly
is exactly in line with what i said in
his character analysis this week as well
baseline is kaido wanted to be the good
guy but plays the villain because he
thinks he's the only one who can change
the world even if it takes some
collateral damage he's straight from his
path trying to force joyboy into
existence automatically disqualifying
himself in the process by using the
people of wano plus he didn't have the
nikanika fruit as well i guess and so i
think luffy will also liberate kaido
from this heavy burden as well we will
see kaido genuinely laughing again and i
think he will end up being on luffy's
side at the end of this fight in some
way or form now while possible in theory
i guess i doubt that kaido will actually
be by luffy's side at the final battle
but much rather sacrifice his life for
the straw hats when the marines or
blackbeard or whoever will inevitably
arrive at some point to make sport of
the winners that way he will finally be
getting the honorable death that he
always wanted having successfully
brought about joyber's return as well
and fingers crossed really hard pressing
really hard it will be yamato who will
join the straw hats and then represent
kaido by luffy's side
okay so with all of that out of the way
now i want to dig deeper into luffy's
power and what the nikanika fruit is
actually based on because the internet
has researched its name to death and
it's not a super obvious mythical
creature like a phoenix or a dragon okay
here's the deal it seems like nika is a
mixture of a couple of different ideas
one element is that of the japanese
buddhist wisdom king deity hyogero calls
luffy the wisdom king myul for instance
it's also referenced in his fight with
enel who has a wisdom king slash
buddha-like form as well who also calls
himself a god
and don't forget skypea was of course
the ark that has the famous panel where
luffy looks like nika which is again
referenced in this chapter as well and
since wisdom kings tend to have fiery
hair as well that might explain that
part of his abilities another part of
nika might be inspired by the almax one
of the oldest known cultural
civilizations in the americas the word
almaq literally translates to rubber
people in english as they actually were
able to produce rubber and cultivate
rubber trees it might also be a nod to
the aztec god of rubber who is called
claustrophobic
nailed it this god's name translated
means the lord of the house of the dawn
which fits pretty nicely to the one who
brings the dawn the sun god don't you
think this god was also associated with
the sun gods representing the eastern
cardinal direction not only would that
tie in nicely with dragons aztec tattoo
and luffy being from brazil but the dawn
is also the sun rising in the east luffy
coming from the east blue okay so we
might now have an idea what nika is
inspired by but what are luffy's actual
powers now because there seems to be two
things in addition to his rubber powers
that do seem new here one luffy's toon
world-like powers that seem to turn
everything around him into a cartoon and
two his firepowers to me at least these
two don't really seem to be the same
thing i feel okay now there is actually
a fantastic theory i have for you guys
that luffy's firepowers are actually not
related to his devil fruit at all but
due to luffy being half lunarian the old
gods like king's flames or sanji's
eyebrows and so if you want to hear that
theory in detail next week make sure to
subscribe to the channel not to miss it
now another option for his firepowers
that was really kindly sent to me by a
guy called renato is that since nika is
the sun gods luffy might just have the
powers of the sun itself quite literally
especially since the sun is a
reoccurring theme in the story now the
entire theory itself is very
science-heavy which is awesome but maybe
a little bit long so what you need to
know right here is that a star like the
sun is basically a giant fusion reactor
and so we've seen luffy using gas and
heat to modify his body which seems to
work in a similar pattern to plasma the
fourth state of matter that is heated
gas for example in this panel here just
a few chapters ago luffy tells us that
he can't let the gas escape his body or
it's over so luffy literally seeming to
melt might be him heating up and
creating plasma inside his rubber body
using the power of the sun itself to
unleash unimaginable forces as being
sake said the morning sun will rise
maybe quite literally and while i really
like that idea a lot it doesn't explain
the cartoony part of his powers what's
the deal with that well basically since
day one luffy's fighting style has
always been somewhat cartoonish but he
had limitations like when he tried that
spinny spinny attack on arlon but got
stuck and almost died in the process now
similarly like in yu-gi-oh toon powers
have incredible potential because they
can go against the laws of time space
gravity and so on it truly seems to
allow luffy to fight in any way he
pleases like expanding his limbs
changing the world around him and
ignoring how physics work in general as
the gorosei explain making people laugh
wherever it goes it's the most
ridiculous power in the world maybe
quite literally as luffy can turn things
into a funny cartoon which would be the
most oda-like thing to do i do feel
personally but knowing this by itself
isn't enough yet i feel we will need to
see how luffy's fight with kaido really
plays out in full to really understand
luffy's true powers and that's why you
really shouldn't skip this video right
here because i explain in detail how
kaido tried to awaken this power himself
and what it means for the end of this
fight and wano